let's talk about how uh where the
censorship is going we got the story on
duckduckgo this is uh gabriel weinberg
who is the ceo and founder of duckduckgo
he tweeted like so many others i am
sickened by russia's invasion so i've
decided to completely and totally
destroy my company no one should ever
use it again it's a garbage i'm just
kidding he didn't say that he actually
might as well kind of exactly
he said like so many others i am
sickened by russia's invasion of ukraine
and that gigantic humanitarian crisis
can it continues to create at duckduckgo
we've been rolling out search updates to
downrank sites associated with russian
disinformation this all makes sense now
in addition to down ranking sites
associated with this information we also
often place news modules and information
box at the top of duckduckgo search
results duckduckgo's mission is to make
simple privacy protection
yeah no that's not your value
proposition dudes so i have a question
for you gabriel um
who determines what's russian
disinformation who determines what's
true and do you have like who at
uh go is the the arbiter of truth and
and morality so i can better understand
what sites you've decided to downrank
duckduckgo is completely worthless at
this point i don't see why anybody would
use them and they are because these last
you know now this is making sense to me
because as i've been trying to do some
research about the conflict that's going
on and trying to get truth because we
know it's a big propaganda problem um
i've been going from google to
duckduckgo and getting the exact same
search results and being very frustrated
by it because i rely on duckduckgo to
give me
you know search results that are
different from different sites than the
ones that google just gives me yeah
absolutely no i mean for a very long
time duckduckgo was far superior to
google when i do work with the
foundation for economic education to
create these educational cartoons we'll
usually have people at their
organization who will do some research
for us if i don't have the time to dive
into all of it and there was a topic
that we needed to dive into and i can't
remember exactly what it was but the
fellow who was doing research kept
saying i can't really find anything
about this on google and he'd been
searching for hours and i said oh just
try duckduckgo and within 15 minutes he
had like 10 links with a lot of really
great information in them and it's just
sad that that resource isn't really a
reliable one take a look at this tweet
right here duckduckgo tweeted on april 6
2019. quote when you search you expect
unbiased results but that's not what you
get on google and that is a quote from
that same guy gabriel weinberg
he's now like privacy is the reason
people use duckduckgo no
no people use duckduckgo because they
know google is censoring information
yeah all right well there's the brave
search people are highlighting brave is
available so everybody switch on over
and we'll keep playing this game of cat
and mouse
maybe we should let this guy know that
he just killed his business tweet on him
i think he's gonna figure it out yeah i
you know what i should log in on twitter
so that i could actively do that during
the show be like gabriel you have but i
did already basically tweet that i said
it duckduckgo i said duckduckgo destroys
their only value proposition with a
single tweet yeah completely i'm
switching over to the brave search
engine right now yeah
so you have your brave browser and then
you gotta go set up the brave search
engine within the browser they're
different okay
well that's what i'm gonna have to do
now yeah it took me so long to get used
to typing duckduckgo and instead of
google because it was such a habit for
me that i'd formed over many years of
exclusively using google before i knew
that they were terrible and duckduckgo
is a terrible you website name to be
completed yeah yeah i know is not good
we should have if this guy ceo wants to
come on and defend himself maybe the cia
gave him a gag order and was like you're
going to be censoring information now
and you're not allowed to talk about why
you think he would tell you that yeah
not on air he might tell ian i mean he's
in a lot of people tell me a lot
so uh there was this uh email service
see if you guys can can look this up
while i'm talking about it where they
got what's called the national security
letter they had encrypted email uh was
it something forged or something i can't
remember they they said that i think it
was like an s the nsa contacted him and
said it's a national security letter
you're not allowed to tell anybody about
this turn over all this information and
he was like nope
and then they were like if you don't do
this you're getting in trouble and then
he went public and was like i got this
letter they're demanding i turn over
information on my clients and then you
know basically they i think they
basically shut down his entire company
so this guy's probably chilling and he's
sitting there thinking like we're doing
a great job of fighting censorship and
there's a knock on the door and there's
a guy in nsa you know badge and he's
like you are from now on going to be
censoring information we don't like and
he goes you got it boss and he goes to a
sweater account he's like we don't like
free information we want censorship
there you go problem with them
centralized power you do not want as a
tech leader you do not want centralized
control of your organization man because
you are the target you got to
decentralize that no one person should
be able to change
a search engine like that in my opinion
it's way too dangerous people can get
co-opted
yup let me see i think i think i found
this story uh
dude is this it from 2013. 2013 story
how the government killed a secure email
company well i don't know if this is the
same company but they say in mid july
tanya lakshina deputy director for human
rights human rights watch moscow office
wrote on a facebook wall that she had
received yes it was lava bit there you
go an email from edward snowden at
lavabit it requested that she attend a
press conference at moscow's
sheriff uh
to share metievo international airport
playing
to discuss the nsa leaker situation
yesterday lava bit went dark an
encrypted statement posted on its
website the services owners and operator
ladder levitz ladar levison wrote i
cannot share my experience over the last
six weeks even though i have twice made
the appropriate requests those
experiences led him to shut down the
service rather than as he put it become
complicit in crimes against the american
people lava users reacted with consumer
vitriol on the company's facebook page
what about our emails the tide quickly
turned toward government critique by the
end of the night a similar service
silent circle also shut down its
encrypted email product calling the
lavabit affair the writing on the wall
so clarification
he refused to give in to the government
and shut it down rather than turn over
people's information good for him yeah
that's great and maybe that's what
happened with duckduckgo maybe they
should they knock on your door one day
and they're like well we can destroy you
and everything you love and own or you
can bend the knee and do as you're told
welcome to the empire yeah it's been so
good to you your whole life now bow well
then what you would never i mean either
way his business is dead so you might as
well have your dignity seriously yeah
man i would have i'd love to be the ceo
of duckduckgo i'm not saying this
actually happened we don't know for sure
but i tell you this if i was the ceo of
this company and then i got a knock on
the door and they're like we want you to
censor information from russian sources
i'd be like no and they would like you
have to and i beg how about i just shut
it down and then then what what are they
gonna do about it and then i'd go public
and be like hey guys the government's
requesting we send her information so
i'm shutting it down
that means
that being said elon musk
was publicly he publicly stated he will
never censor information over starlink
so except at gunpoint
but dude's got
you know some people say there's a thing
called fu money yeah elon musk has
something like f everyone money did he
literally say i would at gunpoint yeah
while he's just inviting gunpowder
[Laughter]
you know i'm trying to use this brave
search it's in beta it's not great yet
that's the downside like i'm going to go
well i'm going to go home i was said
later i'm going to go home later after
the show and get on my computer my
desktop and i've got duckduckgo and
google search
if i really need a good search engine
that can crawl the web i need something
that's tried and true duckduckgo has
been it is my current default me too so
now i have to switch it because i'm not
going to support that yeah like i'm
maybe i'll use it when i'm not searching
for
news but then go to brave when i'm
searching for data about russia i don't
know how this show exists
because you're so charming
and you actually do your research
yeah i guess but like
i don't know man
the government the government the
institutions the establishment democrats
and neocons are trying so hard to drum
up a war
in it between nato and russia we've got
13 000 nato soldiers in estonia right
now i think in sonia and they're firing
stinger missiles and their kamala harris
is in poland and she's saying putin
don't you dare we're coming it's like
that's the opposite of de-escalation
they i i genuinely i think the the nato
would love to get an excuse to just
flatten russia
and they're doing everything in their
power it seems and we're just sitting
here all talking like every night being
like that's bad that's wrong you
shouldn't do it they're lying to the
american people i just don't understand
why we haven't gotten our well we got
swatted six times this year yeah so
maybe that's happening i don't think i i
i for one we've never tested nato right
so it's never really truly been tested
so article 5 has been called on one one
time after 9 11 right and the nato
forces what did they do after 9 11. they
said okay yeah i guess this qualifies
and they sent some jets over to patrol
the u.s skies because that's the only
job is they they have to defend you on
your soil they don't have to go to enemy
soil that's why they didn't go into
afghanistan iraq they did have some you
know some countries were able to opt in
but there wasn't an article five you
know actually invoked in order to force
uh troops to go in anywhere so it's
never really been tested
we don't actually know i mean we sit
here and we posture and we act like oh
yeah we were totally flat in russia but
we don't actually know how we would do
head to head against russia and we also
don't know who would join in with russia
and russia their military is i think
their capabilities around like what 50
60 percent of nato which sounds we don't
know that right right but i will say
this russia's military is unified under
one command structure nato is a bunch of
different countries different languages
different cultures that could be a huge
issue but nato's really only the united
states france the uk and turkey yeah
everybody else just what gives us some
bodies the bodies of people that maybe
are not well trained right so you have
to have
those four countries getting together
and the french are always lately they've
been pretty hesitant to get involved at
all they've got their own problems so
they especially don't like to go with us
to the middle east and turkey same thing
turkey feels a little bit hesitant about
that so and turkey
does is not really embraced very well
you know look look at how uh ukraine is
being embraced and putting in
applications to be joining the eu and
they get the backing of some eu members
and turkey's been applying year after
year after year let us into the eu and
they get snubbed so turkey is
one foot out the door right
i just
for russia and turkey not to be like
lockstep i can't imagine that black sea
you can't get through constantinople
constantinople you can't get through
istanbul without
without turkey well i think that's why
turkey knows that they've been embraced
by nato was just uh just to get
just to sort of uh take some power away
from russia hopefully but turkey's not
100 percent there with us i mean they
really are straddling the line between
the two and i think that at any minute
turkey could actually say you know what
we just want to forget this whole nato
thing we're not really involved in it
historically i mean people switch sides
in the middle of conflict it's not out
of the ballpark just because someone on
paper says they're your ally doesn't
mean that like when realism hits the fan
people do what they need to do to
survive right that's why nato hasn't
really truly been tested and i think
they're afraid to actually do it because
i don't think they know what turkey will
actually do
if they'll really truly send bodies in
to go and confront russians and to
potentially you know to allow thousands
of your own to die for what
so
i just want to say we tested it speak of
the devil what was the full phrase
uh it looks like our chat shut down oh
what i noticed uh because you know we we
have the live chat going and i can see
everything i got a little bit jinxed it
and normally it's just flying like crazy
just chats are coming in like crazy and
so i noticed it stopped moving what and
i was like what's this
there's no chat so i'm like maybe the
browser screwed up so i tried resetting
the chat didn't work i pulled up my
phone and went in there there's no chat
i just posted the message smash the like
button and i don't see it even on my own
phone on the same account so uh
it could be yeah there we go no yeah
is it back as soon as you mentioned
as i was building mines over the decade
i noticed
almost all the time when people think
that you're doing something insidious
technically it's usually like a glitch
yeah no dude no way from my way from my
perspective as an admin it is a glitch
usually it's a glitch
now it's now it's exploded they're like
he's on to us
some admins like people are saying chat
was dead it's back it's broken it's back
it could be a glitch you know the other
night my internet went down and other
people like my internet went down too
like two nights ago did you guys have
internet
you guys have was there all sorts of
tech outages a couple nights ago like is
this like a global attack probably i
mean well i wouldn't have been surprised
yeah yeah yeah lo i'll tell you this man
i think we're already in
world war iii the problem is people
don't like that phrase because it
invokes imagery of of bombings and
blitzkriegs and all that stuff but
people need to understand that nato is
absolutely supplying weapons and
personnel to the ukrainians for a war a
ground war with russia china has already
threatened the u.s that if we take any
any uh economic uh sanctions or actions
against them they'll retaliate against
us so
already china has announced that they're
gonna be supporting russia with the
sanctions with union pay the u.s is
already
i'll put it this way what is war
can you define war for me like
legitimately like off top of your head
kim
two countries battling
maybe that you know because i'm i'm not
trying to put you on any country
how would you define it right we
typically where there's hot war there's
cold war there's economic warfare and
you can battle many ways you don't have
to battle with guns you could battle
with
like it could be cyber war
or you know any kind of really
economic warfare we've seen cyber
attacks across the board we've seen
weird outages happening we've seen
industrial plants exploding and things
like that and
if we're in an information warfare or an
infowar
some texas now you're really looking for
your chat
i think it's fair to say you know we see
all these stories where it's like
anonymous takes down russian
infrastructure and i'm like dude it's
probably the u.s government or its
contractors
it is western interests going after
russia here's here's what blows my mind
the us is like we want to give weapons
to the ukrainians right planes or
whatever poland says we want to give
these planes
if we're providing weaponry to
ukrainians
then latvia says we vote to allow our
citizens to go to ukraine and fight for
the ukrainians i'm like
how is this not a declaration of war
providing resources to one country who's
fighting another oh yeah and like visa
mastercard and american express shut
down axis in russia but it wasn't the
american government that did it so we're
off the hook
isn't you know but it's like oh how much
power do these corporations have so
think about what is the purpose of war
because i i agree with you tim i
actually think we're in world war iii
but i think we've been and i actually i
don't remember which so i actually said
that exact thing on recently but um
but i think it's not because of the
weapons that we're giving and there's
battles going on in ukraine
what is the purpose of war
so when you're going to war with another
country why are you doing it
you're doing it because you're trying to
you don't want them to so we've always
we try to go to war with the soviets to
stop the spread of the soviet union
right so we don't want them to have
dominance or power
in certain parts of the world we want
influence over
different regions and people to our own
benefit right thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there